care for the world knowing them neither
more nor less around the world young
people are realizing these things in a
way that their elders maybe do not and
they are outraged the way in which my
generation have dealt with an utter
world and the tragic situation and
crucial situation of disaster situation
they were handy how got the nerve to
hand over to them and they're making
their voice heard so David's good to me
and you
right now then this is a complicated
situation we got here
yes I do ask you questions and if you're
very unkind you lost me
what has been your funniest moment
whilst filming last year I made a film
about penguins and the film was about a
new project to make a new colony of
penguins kind of we kind of staged a
little experiment we set up these decoy
Penguins on the beach and we filmed
penguins like waddling pass what we
weren't expecting is that they actually
copied the Penguins that were already
there since we see this penguin walking
along and looking going it's a pain when
lying down I guess I'll lie down next to
it too and it lay down and then it's all
we got self-conscious and ran off so the
same to you what's the funniest moment
you can remember I know I suppose like
hey you all know that you're just seeing
yourself up to me to give a piece of
camera and something and then something
happens and I had a producer who in his
wisdom and his understanding of the
natural workings of the natural world
elected to find a place on the banks of
the sambisa River just off where there
was a hippopotamus a male in charge of
his harem okay so you said might say
something now if you know about
hippopotamus is that it will not be put
off and there's no way that you think it
and so I think I did it like five times
maybe six everytime well soon as I got
as far as if we did you never use it
okie-dokie right next up so polar
opposite what's been the most upsetting
moment you filmed
well well when a creatures in agony one
way or another I remember one of the
most heart-rending examples was a friend
of mine who was filming a baby elephant
that was couldn't walk and was dragged
up first there was absolutely nothing he
could do to get that little baby
elephant to the waterhole which was
maybe a half a day's march away
there's no way in which its parent could
help it its parents are standing in card
overing it's if you'd tried to help it
in any case it would have charged and
it's heart-rending your hearts if you're
there more than anybody else let alone
when people tell you that how heartless
you were being a letting poor animal die
any any kill any kill that you see is
heart-rending I mean you're not human if
you want I mean and to see a baby animal
that was being taken by a leopard or
cheetah or something how do you maintain
that that distance when you're there in
the field well it's it's a strange thing
isn't it
and yet you know very well that if you
interfered you will almost certainly
make things worse and the fact of the
matter is that leopard babies or cheetah
babies cheetah cubs they also have to
keep and be fed and they can only be
found by killing things so your job is
to try and record the natural world and
by and large you do best to stand back
and just see what what goes on and tries
to understand it yeah I've gotten these
challenges this is that tricky one
describe a time an animal made you think
differently about the world I'm glad
you're answering this than me yeah so I
did a zoology degree and one of the
first things we had to do when I'd
studied at Manchester was wait to go to
the Manchester Museum and pick an animal
basically just right little presentation
about it and I chose a sponge
and because it looked quite weird I
thought it was quite cold and I didn't
really know anything about it
and I started reading into it and I
found out this realized that they don't
have any tissues they don't have any
nerves they don't have any organs they
have basically just a big blob of cells
and yet they are animals they've kind of
described as like basic or less advanced
compared to other animals and yet they
have a way of life that works I mean
they're largely unchanged for hundreds
of millions of years they're quite
content that they're at the bottom the
ocean essentially just filtering food
through themselves surviving I started
just sort of rethink the way I looked at
nature because whether it's a beautiful
lion or a strange-looking peculiar
sponge at the bottom the city pity
you've chosen that because there is a
kind of sponge called you Peck Tellez
you know you Peck teller which is
otherwise known as Venus's flower basket
and in some extraordinary way it builds
a complex tube which has hexagonal
apertures to it of the most delicate
beauty the sponge sucks in water into
its middle and then squirts out of the
top and you Peck teller does that and
with the what comes in are often the
larvae that the baby fish hold fire a
very very small fish that swimming
through the lattice of this wonderful
structure and it stays there because the
food water coming in but carrying in
edible particles but of course it's
grows so it makes an a prison for itself
so it so it lives within the sponge all
its life and I suppose hopes to goodness
it's gonna find a mate that's gonna come
in at the same time but that too led me
to the similar sort of thought to it I
think I've had up until that point I've
had a very human biased view on nature
and I'd kind of thought that some
animals were better than others might
more evolved than others and I start to
realize that nothing's more like
advanced and nothing is better
of life is amazing and exists in the
perfect in the best way it can for the
its environment and occupies its own
niche and everything is kind of worthy
of our interests and our respects okay
next up what's the most significant
consequence of climate change you've
witnessed I suppose it's a coral reef
really it's the warming of the Seas and
the first time I swam and the tropics
which is back now in the 50s the first
dive I did was on the most complex the
most beautiful the most breathtaking
animal community which is a coral reef
where there are 50 completely different
animals that you've never seen before in
your life all externally beautiful all
interacting sort of way and I went back
to that same reef about what house Perth
25 years later when global warming had
caused the rise in the reef and the
acidity and the carbon dioxide as well
as the temperature and that reef was
like a graveyard to start with it looks
rather dramatic and beautiful because
it's pure white dead but then brown alga
develops all over it so it looks foul
and decaying which is what it is and
that was
I've recently last year dived on a
quarry for the first time and it was the
most amazing thing I've ever seen I
agree yeah it's unbelievable it's it's
otherworldly mmm it's it's a hundred
times better than even you'd imagine
like if you went and I think I agree I
think that's one of the most terrifying
things the fact that easily within my
lifetime this could be I mean that could
be an experience that my kids or
grandkids don't he's impossible for them
yeah and you know and I'll be telling
them like they look in an aquarium and I
will say to them okay you know those
those things used to exist in the wild
yes and what's more you will never get
an aquarium like about it like a reef of
diversity and richness okay and if you
could deliver one message to the younger
generation what would it be fun care for
the world knowing them neither more nor
less around the world young people are
realizing these things in a way that
their elders maybe do not and they are
outraged the way in which my generation
have dealt with another world and the
tragic situation and crucial situation
of disaster situation they were handling
how got the nerve to hand over to them
and they're making their voice heard
they said with total conviction and
great profundity and great passion and
we should listen just give you hope
I don't think it's gonna get better in
your time if you can hold it back to
where we are now you all have done a
great thing but my suspicion is that
we're going to lose a bunch of species
yet before we can get things under
control we aren't the only organ living
organisms on this earth on this planet
we have no right if we make it
impossible for other animals to live on
we are killing ourselves we are totally
dependent upon the natural world for
every mouthful of food we eat and every
tongue full of breath that we take but
the other thing of course is that in the
end with the climate change we will get
great shifts in population with CY eyes
you'll get the cities that have been
built on the sea which is most of the
great capitals of the over the world
and they will certainly be flooding so
we must get together and as a world
population acted together and that's
never been achieved before in the
history of the planet but it has to
happen now it just has to happen
otherwise the whole nations are going to
be wiped out so caring for the natural
role it could not be more important okay
over to you thank you that's absolutely
free